so
ja meine Damen und Herren sie müssen
nicht unbeunruhigt nach links schauen
wir haben keinen neuen Bundeskanzler
daheim der heißt auch nicht Harald
Schmidt trotzdem kommen Harald Schmidt
jetzt auf die Bühne ist es aber auch
nicht so dass der Bundeskanzler nicht
kommt es ist allein so dass der
regierungsflieger ein bisschen
Verspätung hat und gerade gelandet ist
und der Bundeskanzler jetzt noch hierher
fahren muss und um sie nicht zu lange
warten zu lassen machen wir jetzt und
ich sag's ungern brauchen wir einen
Pausen Clown
wer eignet sich besser als Harald
Schmidt der jetzt für 10 Minuten hier
hoch kommt im Gespräch mit Reinhard
Müller und nachher noch mal darf dann
aber oben insofern Schmidt
[Applaus]
guten Tag
davon träumt man ja
könnte ja sagen herrscht mit
sportpalaststimmung oder Entschuldigung
sportpalaststörung auch gefährlich
ja
bei einem Kölner Vermögensverwalter da
äh klemmte die Maschine von Sigmar
Gabriel
und ich habe gefragt ob ich mit meinen
Worten antworten soll oder wie Gabriel
oder waren Antworten
auch gefragt sind Sie mit dem Kanzler
gekommen dass er gesagt nicht das würde
mein Marktwert zu weit runterziehen
ja gibt's auch eine Zeiten wenn du beim
Humor
Zeitenwende nicht nur
ich kenne überhaupt keine Zeit
ja deutsche Panzer rollen wieder gegen
Osten also wie alles so
es wurde dann vor zwei Jahren gesagt wir
sind in einer anderen Welt aufgebracht
da würde ich schon mal sagen hängt davon
ab in welcher ich eingeschlafen bin am
Abend vorher ja und das sind einfach so
Behauptungen die gemacht werden die
werden dann übernommen ähm genauso wie
der Satz ja mal Zeit lang gefeiert wurde
in Deutschland gefeiert wie diese
Verteidigung zu Ende ging aber auch
erlebt also ich bin da sehr vorsichtig
die Ampel humoristisch was her oder ist
das eher Business sehr gut oder
humoristisch sie ist gar nicht so ich
sehe er macht taktisch ja also ich kenne
das ja ich hatte ja lange Zeit eine
fernsehproduktionsgesellschaft und man
lässt da sozusagen die die zweite Reihe
gegeneinander laufen
um selber dann zu entscheiden in welchem
Punkt man einsteigt und wie man sich
verhält und was da jetzt genau rauskommt
ich habe gestern in der FAZ gelesen
hauptsächlich leben ja der
Wirtschaftsminister und seine Frau als
Übersetzer von Tattoos
und das heißt wir haben doch die
deutsche Entsprechung jetzt zu teduce
und Sylvia Plath im
Wirtschaftsministerium und können mir
vorstellen dass es uns alle nach vorne
bringt
es gehen wir mal weg vom demokratischen
pulletariat König Karl ist ja gerade zu
Gast er wird auch mit Salutschüssen
begrüßt da wäre vielleicht auch der
Munitionsmangel bei der Bundeswehr aber
man sieht doch so eine gewisse Verehrung
der Deutschen sind ja auch schon
verklappt ist ja nicht verkauft ah
glühende royalist und ich habe schon mal
den dunkelblauen zwei Reiher bewundert
indem er am Brandenburger Tor stand
während ja unsere First Lady mit den
Pumps im Kopfsteinpflaster hängen
geblieben ist ja und das ist einfach so
ein Klassen Unterschied der ist nicht
erlernbar ja
ähm
und wir haben natürlich auch die
deutschen Leistungsträger im Frack sehr
sehr gut gefallen
ausgeschlossen ja ich habe getippt wer
hat ein bei wem ist es ein live-ruck und
man muss sich ja auch da drin bewegen
können ja wenn man sieht wie Charles
gestern am Pult im im Parlament stand
das ist einfach mit diesem Anzug der
wirklich aufgebügelt wie oft tätowiert
auf ihn und es nutzt da nix sie für so
einen Abend mal zu verkleiden sondern
das ist die Royal Family weiß einfach
gar nicht das ist auch anders geht
allein wie sie aus dem Bentley
ausgestiegen sind ja also ich bin
glühender Fan des englischen
Königshauses und hatte eigentlich
insgeheim gehofft dass Harry im vorher
jedes Bundestags noch ein Bücherstand
aufbaut ja
[Applaus]
als Überraschung ja mit seinem
schwäbischen Bestseller spare ja das
stimmt
ja damit eröffne ich sonst möbelhäuser
man schüttet ja Gräben zu wo es nur geht
ja das englische Königshaus ist ja
eigentlich ein deutsches ja also wer
soll wenn man mal auf unser Land kommen
Deutschland denn nun regieren die
Hohenzollern oder Heinrich iviertel nein
ich würde eigentlich sagen dass wir uns
wenn dem englischen Königshaus
anschließen ja bei uns ist das alles ein
bisschen verkrampft und zu viele Brüche
und ich habe irgendwo mal gelesen die
die Engländer kannst ja nicht mal einen
Weihnachtsbaum bevor Albert kam zu
Viktoria und ähm ich finde es eigentlich
dass das sinnvollste da muss jetzt
irgendeine sie auf der EU was finden
lassen dass wir sozusagen eine
Demokratie bleiben eine parlamentarische
aber trotzdem und sei mal jetzt im im
repräsentativen Bereich von den
windsores vertreten lassen also ähm ich
gehe aber auch wirklich stärker vom vom
Outfit her und wenn wenn es ist einfach
was anderes als
m ich möchte nicht respektierlich
erscheinen aber so wenn die Gattin den
eigenen Namen behält um weiter als
sozialrichterin brillieren zu können ist
es was anderes als wenn Camilla da
auftaucht über die an meine Freunde von
dem englischen Hochadel sagen sie ist
der Typ schmutzige Gummistiefel ja
und ich weiß genau was gemeint ist und
ich bewundere sie dafür und welcher
deutsche Politiker innen hat dann am
meisten royalen touch
ich würde schon sagen eigentlich
Alexander Graf Lambsdorff
unser neuer Mann in Moskau und wer das
auch hat auch hat sieht ja aus als wäre
in Burberry geboren ist Konstantin von
Notz von den Grünen ja also wenn ich mir
die Bandbreite von Konstantin von Notz
über Ricarda lang bist du um die nuripur
vorstelle
muss ich sagen da ist bei den Grünen
wirklich alles abgedeckt ja
kurze Frage wann kommt deine Kanzler ich
habe die ewig Zeit ja
sie haben ja Herr Schmidt aus Würmer
Begeisterung für Guttenberg geäußert da
kommt ganz neuer schmiss rein oder muss
man den reanimieren den Gutenberg
KT wie wir bei der Linken ihnen ja
ich glaube der ist so der ist so happy
da in seinem ähm Geschäftsbereich jetzt
wie auch heute morgen Sebastian Kunst
war da jemand von ihnen schon hier oder
hat dem Stream gesehen er war nicht
schlecht oder er war nicht schlecht live
ist was anderes als mitschreiben her
sage ich immer
immer das Genre berücksichtigen also
nein ich glaube Karl-Theodor zu
Guttenberg ist nicht mehr interessiert
noch mal in die Politik zu gehen
Stichwort warten auf den Kanzler Wigald
bonig hat mal gesagt dann werden Witz
über kohlreißt der kommt ihm vor wie ein
Töpfer aus dem vergangenen Jahrhundert
ist stolz auch so ein Fall der steht
irgendwie für sich also aber ich finde
er macht es sehr sehr gut und er hat
natürlich bei Angela Merkel gelernt wie
es geht ja
ja nicht vergessen wahnsinnig erfahren
er war auch schon bei Gerhard Schröder
Minister ich habe überlegt kriegst gar
nicht mehr er war glaube ich schon er
war Arbeitsminister
er war Hamburg was regieren über
Bürgermeister in Hamburg und so weiter
und
schon wieder muss ich dir lassen Sie die
FAZ gelegentlicher
ist gut ist für mich ein bisschen sehr
jung geworden ja so im Netz ja wir haben
so ein paar junge verrückte jetzt das
ist nicht mehr meine FAZ aber ich ziehe
mich ich ziehe mich an den Leserbriefen
wieder
[Gelächter]
[Applaus]
ja
aber
wieso lesen Sie das Netz es war die
gedruckte Zeitung nämlich an doch ja ich
gehe jeden Tag zum Kiosk weil ich gern
zum Kiosk gehe ja da stehen ja dann auch
Herrschaften in so einer Cordhose wie
man hier in Frankfurt schon mal
abgeführt wird ja und
da habe ich gelesen das letzten Endes
und das kann ja jeder bestätigen die
Deutschen wollen eigentlich keine
Veränderung 16 Jahre Helmut Kohl 16
Jahre Angela Merkel Schröder auch 7
Jahre was heißt das für Schulze gucken
wie lange wir Fußballtrainer
Nationaltrainer haben und so weiter und
die Leute wollen nicht dieses ich rede
Klartext ich haut drauf sondern schön
abwarten ja äh einzeln die Probleme
scheibchenweise lösen sich nicht sinnlos
was auf dem Tisch ziehen was gar nicht
aktuell ist und und dieses dieses Weinen
in den Tagesthemen und so weiter ja und
bei habe ich merkt man ja schon dass es
sehr substanziell wird das Leiter immer
mit echt kein Scheiß jetzt Leute ja so
dann wird 's ganz menschlich und ähm und
dann ernsthaft zu sagen dieser Job ist
so hart seid seit einer Woche es sich
Müsli mit kaltem Wasser
er hat zumindest kaltes Wasser das haben
wir auch zwei Drittel der Menschheit
nicht ja also das ich glaube dass ich
würde fast die Prognose wagen Olaf
Scholz bleibt über die Legislaturperiode
hinaus Kanzler weil die Deutschen sagen
da wissen wir in etwa woran wir sind und
wer dann letzten Endes das Kabinett mit
auffüllt dafür haben wir den Souverän
der das entscheiden wird und März macht
weiter Opposition die nächsten 40 Jahre
schon zu lange dabei auch ja nicht
wirklich ein großer Global Player
gewesen sondern glaube ich die
regionalabteilung von Blackrock geleitet
[Musik]
das Flugzeug ist auch eine Boeing keine
Boeing also
nee ich glaube das ist
sehe ich nicht die Frage ist wen bringen
die Grünen als Spitzenkandidat Karies
momentan bisschen an erzählt
die Annalena baerbock scheint man die
das geklaute Buch den vom Bürgerrecht
herkommt verziehen zu haben sie hat gute
Bilder ich habe sie neulich gesehen mit
so einer sehr schicken Sonnenbrille in
einem Kahn im Irak zu Besuch um sich
dort mal ein Bild zu machen und
also das einen Eindruck zu verschaffen
meine ich und ähm sind sie auch so ein
verklappter grüner der Jaguar fährt
Verbrenner natürlich und dann aus
Ablasshandel noch viel besser sage ich
mache immer Wahlomat ja und die Partei
kam bei mir raus 50 % Übereinstimmung
grüne 50% AFD ja ja ich war geschockt
50% grüne ja
das heißt wenn das rauskommt bin ich
erledigt ja
und das heißt aber das ist das
Bedenkliche kaum ist noch mal für
Waffenlieferung und Kriegseinsätze wird
man in so eine grüne Ecke gedrängt und
ja
dagegen muss ich mich natürlich wehren
Helene du hast dich in fdp-farben aber
du willst was anderes
das ist heute auch schon auf Handy
abzulesen ne ja kommt er denn mit dem
Auto oder mit dem Hubschrauber genau da
ich merke dass ich das hier langsam tot
läuft
[Applaus]
das ist eine tolle Party weil ich habe
sie heute morgen mit Sebastian Kurz
gesehen ja
[Gelächter]
also
einfach ja also wie ist das Möbelhaus
wenn der Verkäufer kommt bei mir war es
so ich war meine Talkshow und dann wurde
ich gefragt wie lange machst du noch
dann sage ich bis mich keiner mehr sehen
will und dann noch zehn Jahre
worauf Sepp Maier der mit in der
talkshirt sagt rum
sehr gut so einfach was zu Sebastian
Gott sagen dann tun Sie es jetzt nein
wahnsinnig genossen sie und der Kollege
Simon Strauß sie waren sehr gut
vorbereitet sie waren sehr hart aber es
ist natürlich ein Unterschied ob man das
jemand also ob man schreibt ja oder ob
man das jemand fragt der mit allen
Wasser gewaschen ist und der der uns
also mustergültig war das zu lernen der
einstiegssatz von ihm war immer kann man
so sehen aber kann man so sehen aber da
gibt es ersten
Politprofi gegenüber sitzen oder beim
Maischberger der Stichworte geben ja
das ist
ja ja
heute am längeren Hebel setzen darf ich
Sie jetzt bitte die Bühne zu verlassen
[Applaus]
sie sehen die beiden Herren ja später
noch mal wer möchte
[Applaus]